JOSH GORDON:
Classifiers are only
as good as the
features you provide.
That means coming up
with good features
is one of your most important
jobs in machine learning.
But what makes a good
feature, and how can you tell?
If you're doing
binary classification,
then a good feature
makes it easy to decide
between two different things.
For example, imagine we
wanted to write a classifier
to tell the difference
between two types of dogs--
greyhounds and Labradors.
Here we'll use two features--
the dog's height in inches
and their eye color.
Just for this toy example,
let's make a couple assumptions
about dogs to keep
things simple.
First, we'll say that
greyhounds are usually
taller than Labradors.
Next, we'll pretend that
dogs have only two eye
colors-- blue and brown.
And we'll say the
color of their eyes
doesn't depend on
the breed of dog.
This means that one of
these features is useful
and the other tells us nothing.
To understand why, we'll
visualize them using a toy
dataset I'll create.
Let's begin with height.
How useful do you
think this feature is?
Well, on average,
greyhounds tend
to be a couple inches taller
than Labradors, but not always.
There's a lot of
variation in the world.
So when we think
of a feature, we
have to consider how it
looks for different values
in a population.
Let's head into Python for
a programmatic example.
I'm creating a
population of 1,000
dogs-- 50-50 greyhound Labrador.
I'll give each of them a height.
For this example, we'll
say that greyhounds
are on average 28 inches
tall and Labradors are 24.
Now, all dogs are
a bit different.
Let's say that height
is normally distributed,
so we'll make both of these
plus or minus 4 inches.
This will give us two
arrays of numbers,
and we can visualize
them in a histogram.
I'll add a parameter so
greyhounds are in red
and Labradors are in blue.
Now we can run our script.
This shows how many dogs in our
population have a given height.
There's a lot of
data on the screen,
so let's simplify it and
look at it piece by piece.
We'll start with
dogs on the far left
of the distribution-- say,
who are about 20 inches tall.
Imagine I asked you to predict
whether a dog with his height
was a lab or a greyhound.
What would you do?
Well, you could figure out
the probability of each type
of dog given their height.
Here, it's more likely
the dog is a lab.
On the other hand,
if we go all the way
to the right of the
histogram and look
at a dog who is
35 inches tall, we
can be pretty confident
they're a greyhound.
Now, what about a
dog in the middle?
You can see the graph
gives us less information
here, because the probability
of each type of dog is close.
So height is a useful
feature, but it's not perfect.
That's why in machine
learning, you almost always
need multiple features.
Otherwise, you could just
write an if statement
instead of bothering
with the classifier.
To figure out what types
of features you should use,
do a thought experiment.
Pretend you're the classifier.
If you were trying to
figure out if this dog is
a lab or a greyhound, what other
things would you want to know?
You might ask about
their hair length,
or how fast they can run,
or how much they weigh.
Exactly how many
features you should use
is more of an art
than a science,
but as a rule of thumb,
think about how many you'd
need to solve the problem.
Now let's look at another
feature like eye color.
Just for this toy
example, let's imagine
dogs have only two eye
colors, blue and brown.
And let's say the
color of their eyes
doesn't depend on
the breed of dog.
Here's what a histogram might
look like for this example.
For most values, the
distribution is about 50/50.
So this feature
tells us nothing,
because it doesn't correlate
with the type of dog.
Including a useless feature
like this in your training
data can hurt your
classifier's accuracy.
That's because there's a chance
they might appear useful purely
by accident, especially if
you have only a small amount
of training data.
You also want your
features to be independent.
And independent
features give you
different types of information.
Imagine we already have a
feature-- height and inches--
in our dataset.
Ask yourself,
would it be helpful
if we added another feature,
like height in centimeters?
No, because it's perfectly
correlated with one
we already have.
It's good practice to remove
highly correlated features
from your training data.
That's because a
lot of classifiers
aren't smart enough to
realize that height in inches
in centimeters are
the same thing,
so they might double count
how important this feature is.
Last, you want your features
to be easy to understand.
For a new example,
imagine you want
to predict how many
days it will take
to mail a letter between
two different cities.
The farther apart the cities
are, the longer it will take.
A great feature to use
would be the distance
between the cities in miles.
A much worse pair
of features to use
would be the city's locations
given by their latitude
and longitude.
And here's why.
I can look at the
distance and make
a good guess of how long it
will take the letter to arrive.
But learning the relationship
between latitude, longitude,
and time is much harder
and would require many more
examples in your training data.
Now, there are
techniques you can
use to figure out exactly
how useful your features are,
and even what combinations
of them are best,
so you never have to
leave it to chance.
We'll get to those
in a future episode.
Coming up next time, we'll
continue building our intuition
for supervised learning.
We'll show how different
types of classifiers
can be used to solve the same
problem and dive a little bit
deeper into how they work.
Thanks very much for watching,
and I'll see you then.